it's been called toxic a silent killer
and straight up poison sugar has
consistently and in many cases
exclusively been blamed for the Obesity
epidemic along with the rising rates of
deadly chronic disease but is sugar
actually the one to blame the answers
might surprise you
[Music]
very quickly a thank you to my colleague
Eric Williamson PhD and RD from unlocked
Fitness and Nutrition a nutrition
coaching company that specializes in
Fitness and weight management I'm going
to be sharing some links to their
website and content if you're looking
for personalized support in your
nutrition Journey that I can endorse
also before we get into this very
important controversial topic a quick
note from today's sponsor let me hop in
to tell you about today's sponsor merge
restaurant so you guys know that I love
my games and I also love my food in fact
before I was a YouTuber I was actually a
restaurant food blogger so I know a lot
about the restaurant world and one thing
I know is that it's super exciting but
it's stressful AF you get all the fun
bits without any of the financial
stresses of running a restaurant so you
get to design your own restaurant with
Furniture decorations and the menu which
is really my favorite part
um basically the story follows a girl
named Nina as she overcomes her
restaurant rival but as you play you get
to come up with all these new fun
recipes by merge ingredients in your own
personalized way you also get to unlock
different themes and restaurants so
there's like an Italian Vineyard Beach
barbecue American Diner Japanese garden
Etc if you're into food this is
strangely addictive I played a lot of
games but I've really never played
anything like this so if you want a new
evening routine to unwind with
especially if you're into restaurant and
food culture check out the link in my
bio or scan this QR code to download
merge restaurant for free okay so Google
sugar is bad and you will get millions
of list calls and blogs about how sugar
and sugar alone is basically making you
fat old or Die Young and Lee's claims
are grounded in some evidence but
they've generally been sensationalized
and oversimplified to the point of
having no real meaning at all so let me
give you the hard truths and the
specifics of how much you can eat to
minimize your risk while I make myself a
little sweet treat fear number one sugar
causes a dangerous spike in blood sugar
and Insulin so between very scary
looking graphs on your for you page and
the trend of influencers using
continuous glucose monitors there's a
lot of Buzz right now about blood sugars
and Insulin but very quickly a little
physiology lesson here to explain what
all this means when we consume a
carbohydrate containing food and also
protein to some extent but we're going
to keep it really super simple here our
body releases insulin to store that
sugar in our liver muscles or in body
fat after which our blood sugars will
fall this is a totally normal
physiological process that helps apply
our body with fuel and maintain blood
sugar homeostasis of course influencers
without diabetes are interpreting
literally any fluctuation in blood sugar
as dangerous and disease-causing
suggesting that we should base basically
fear perfectly nutritious whole sugar
containing foods like fruit and this is
incredibly short-sighted for one yeah
and you will see a little blip in your
blood sugar when you consume a high
glycemic index food like a tablespoon of
sugar all on its own but a most foods
that contain sugar also contain things
like fat protein fiber and all those
things help to lower the glycemic index
so like that peach we talked about is a
really great example and B unless you're
Mary Poppins most of us aren't having a
spoonful of sugar all on its own
we are pairing it with other macros that
lower the glycemic index as I discussed
in my video on continuous glucose
monitors the main short-term outcome of
a blood sugar spike in someone with a
healthy working pancreas is that it just
doesn't feel so good right like you get
a little tired you get a little moody
maybe a little hungry too use Snickers
better
There Yet the internet loves to harp on
the subsequent release of insulin as
being inflammatory and fat storing now
we have like discussed this ad nauseam
on my channel here but it's actually not
the release of insulin that influences
health or body weight it's insulin
resistance that influences health and
calorie balance which then influences
our body weight far more than sugar
consumption alone so bottom line insulin
is not the problem insulin resistance is
and we're going to talk a lot more about
what that means in a hot minute fear
number two sugar causes chronic disease
so first of all it is true that excess
sugar is consistently associated with
everything from like obesity diabetes to
cancer to liver disease to dementia to
early mortality but as with anything in
the nutrition world just because sugar
consumption is associated with poor
outcomes doesn't mean it directly or
specifically causes it influencers love
to call out sugar as inflammatory even
though they probably don't even really
know what that means but inflammation is
not just looking puffy or bloated
inflammation is just your body's
response to a potential Intruder an
acute inflammation isn't actually a
concern it's like normal and natural and
it's actually a pretty important bodily
process in fact your body is technically
in a state of inflammation after you
work out and that's what we call the
pump sales thing to me as the coming
years but it's the chronic inflammation
that leads to disease and the research
clearly shows no direct impact of sugar
on inflammation in individuals with
healthy weights so let's consider
consider an extreme population you know
the athletes on the Tour de France were
consuming over 500 grams of sugar per
day and some Elite Runners are consuming
well over 100 grams of sugar every day
for years if sugar was truly
inflammatory and disease-causing all on
its own these athletes would all be
dying middle age when in reality
endurance athletes have like the lowest
levels of inflammation lowest risk of
diseases and diabetes and some of the
longest life expectancies compared to
you know other populations so no sugar
itself is not causing inflammation or
chronic disease what's at play here is
what we call a mediating factor which
basically explains the relationship
between two things B is the mediator
between a and c and in this case if a is
sugar and C is disease the strongest
mediator is believed to be excess weight
specifically excess visceral fat around
the midsection bottom line sugar alone
does not cause inflammation order
disease but if it encourages excess
weight gain it can increase our risk
next let's narrow in on the disease
that's almost exclusively related or
associated with sugar type 2 diabetes
now again there's absolutely a strong
association between sugar consumption
and type 2 diabetes but again sugar
cannot solely be to blame so for one
type diabetes is almost 50 hereditary so
one person could eat only sugars and not
develop insulin resistance while someone
else might eat a really high protein
keto diet their entire life and be
predisposed but genetics aside for a
second it really does come down to the
mediators that we just discussed so the
main one here as we discussed is obesity
specifically visceral and excess liver
fat coupled with inactivity so I need a
knife to put it super simply if we are
chronically consuming high glycemic
index carbohydrates which leads to a
caloric Surplus our pancreas has to work
really really hard to pump out insulin
to bring our blood sugar levels back
down with a surplus of calories and
carbohydrates we can essentially end up
with very full glycogen stores and
expanded fat stores which pushes more
carbs and fat to be stored around the
organs like the liver and because our
liver can actually detect that blood
glucose is there it pumps out even more
glucose pose into the bloodstream so now
your insulin levels are super high your
blood glucose levels are also super high
and your pancreas starts to poop out
and this is what causes diabetes that
said rarely does this happen without a
caloric surface an increase in body fat
body fat produces metabolites that
inhibit glucose uptake so it makes it
harder for insulin to do its job ditto
for inactivity and just like not moving
your body and this is why we see in
studies where calories are controlled
and there's no change in body
composition or body weight we actually
don't see the link between sugar intake
and diabetes risk so bottom line sugar
consumption does not cause diabetes and
if we were to take genetics out of the
equation for a moment excess sugar
consumption coupled with obesity
specifically High visceral and liver fat
plus inactivity is more specifically
what increases the risk so like if
you're an athlete living off those
glucose gels through your intense
training session your insulin
sensitivity is probably just fine so now
let's Zone in on that mediating factor
and talk about the fear that Sugar
causes obesity so first of all like
diabetes obesity is incredibly
hereditary it's thought to be around 40
to 70 percent that said there's loads of
data linking sugar consumption to weight
gain but there are even a lot of
mediating steps involved here as well so
refined sugars and other refined
carbohydrates are rapidly digested and
absorbed so they don't keep you feeling
full very long then of course we find
ourselves hungry again soon after which
means that we need to eat more calories
over the course of the day and this is
why my Hunger crushing combo recommends
dressing up naked carbs with a source of
fiber approaching and fat to slow down
that nutrient absorption and to support
satiety and this would explain why we
don't see an association with sugar
consumption from whole foods that
contain sugar like fruit or dairy where
those sugars are bound up with Hunger
crushing compounds in fact the research
suggests the exact opposite it's also
worth noting that non-sugar foods like
refined grains or processed meats or
fried foods like french fries as well as
just not exercising are just as much
associated with weight gain as sugar is
and there's another piece to this puzzle
so often foods that are high in refined
sugars are also high in fat and or salt
and this unique mixture of sugar and fat
not only makes for an even higher
calorie food but it also evolutionarily
has been shown to be extra rewarding to
our brains basically these Foods
contribute to like a high calorie to low
satiety ratio but also because they're
so rewarding to our dopamine levels
they're more likely to be over consumed
you don't need me to tell you that so
bottom line if we consider these simple
mechanisms it's not enough to say that
Sugar causes obesity we have to say that
high sugar intake leads to lowfulness at
meals and higher dopamine release which
leads to higher calorie intake which
leads to an increased risk of obesity
which then increases the risk of
inflammation and disease see we got to
bring this all full circle here and
speaking of Full Circle
really
really toxic as they say well in a
vacuum no straight up sugar is never
going to be like a superfood it's got
low nutrient density and a poor satiety
profile its main selling feature is that
it's delicious and it brings us joy but
that doesn't mean that it's
as with anything context is really
important so we have to consider how
much are we eating what are we eating it
with and like how is it affecting our
overall energy balance and our body
weight so here are my evidence-based
suggestions for managing your sugar
intake number one let's talk how much So
currently the guidelines suggest no more
than 10 percent of calorie intake should
be coming from added sugars in your diet
for most people that's around one and a
half cans of soda or a slice of cake or
one and a half chocolate bars this does
not include whole food sources like
natural sugars from fruit or dairy which
again as we talked about are bound up
with blood sugar regulating compounds
next we need to think about what we're
eating it with and this is where my
Hunger crushing combo comes in so
pairing my chocolate chips with some
Greek yogurt some hemp hearts some
coconuts some fruit in there fiber
Protein healthy fats not only does this
make for a more satiating snack or
dessert that kind of helps to Edge out
the portion size of the chocolate but it
also helps to control the blood sugar
response and finally how is it affecting
our body weight and physical activity
levels if we stick to suggestion one and
two this piece typically falls into
place but as I've talked about excess
visceral body fat and inactivity are far
better predictors of insulin resistance
than the sugar that you eat itself so if
we're engaging in daily physical
activity and keeping a nutrient dense
energy balanced diet we are less likely
to be putting ourselves at risk so I
hope this helps to tone down some of the
anxiety that you might have around sugar
consumption I didn't want to get into
sugar addiction because I have a whole
other video covering that but I do
acknowledge that for some people having
a little bit of sugar in the house or in
the diet can be a slippery slope but if
you're able to enjoy it in moderation I
absolutely see nothing wrong with a
regular treat and very quickly again a
big thank you to Eric Williamson for all
of his help on this video and the
research I am going to be linking to his
social media and website below thanks
again to merge restaurant for sponsoring
today's video be sure to check out the
link to download free today and on that
note that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on what nutrition questions you
want me to answer next subscribe to the
channel folks and don't forget to
download my free Hunger cushion combo
ebook I'm going to leave the link to
that below as well and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
thank you